what are some tips for finding a new
community when going against what most
people would normally do do this is like
the age to find a new community I mean
we are living in the time where I feel
like it's really really easy to find
people who are like you I mean you know
a hundred years ago I mean you can't
just go to meetup.com and find people
who are interested in the things you're
interested and you can't just you know
go to Facebook and find groups that that
you can fit into so I mean I think if
you're gonna find a new community like
now now's the time to do it yeah to me
there really is a push and pull with
social media of I see the bad of it very
easily and I also see the good of it
very easily and it just becomes very
simple to find your group online by
searching for your group and by looking
into those things and it's like we
talked about with miss VidCon like we
wouldn't have known that that would have
been so great for us have we not gone
I'm gonna take a chance on this right
and and by taking that chance you
realize oh wow this is really great but
sometimes you take that chance and it
doesn't pay off and you just have to
take more chances and hope that they pay
off than you do that don't and you're
gonna run into that realizing the the
sunk costs of like don't hold on to like
okay I took that chance but now I have
to stick with that community because I
tried it out and I've already invested
three weeks of my life into this and so
now I'm stuck with it forever no no
that's a sunk cost you've invested the
time be willing to walk away at any time
if it's no longer adding value the same
is true with some of the the conferences
you talked about Riley if you go to a
conference one year and it's great in
the second year it's just okay the third
year and you're like well wait a minute
this is turned into a networking event
right it could be that you're just no
longer getting what you initially got
from and that's a you don't go to
kindergarten for three years and expect
to have like the third year of
kindergarten be as as equally beneficial
as the first year sometimes you outgrow
the thing you got what you needed to get
from the community and now it's time to
maybe go start your own community or be
a leader as opposed to someone who's
just embedded in a particular community
yeah the one thing I'll add is like
you've got a let go of any expectation -
like when you are when you are reaching
out to new community like you cannot you
got a you have to alleviate as many
expectations as poss
we'll be open and be you know ready for
anything
but if I wanted to go you know join a
knitting meetup group and I thought like
this is it like I'm really passionate
about knitting and this is gonna be and
then I go there and I don't like the
people in the group I'm actually not
that passionate about it I could very
easily start to get down on oh man
that's what I get for branching out it's
like you can't you can't get down on
yourself if you try something new and
you don't like it or the community's not
right for you that's okay like go out
and do that ten more times like go out
and fail as much as possible when trying
to join a new community that's you
actually expect to fail maybe that's
what it is like maybe that have to be
the expectation because you're probably
gonna get much better than that and if
you think about giving more than you get
when you join a new community so we have
a community we have a paid community the
people can join in they ask us all the
time how can I get the most out of this
community and like you're thinking about
it wrong you need to show up for other
people because you're new so you need to
give value before you can get value from
this and when you do we see it every
time when someone shows up and they're
answering questions they're being
helpful they're not asking for anything
people love those people but when you
show up to the party and you run in and
you're like I've got a thing look at my
thing and you know you take that thing
with everyone take it
people just go like ah what are you
doing like why are you why are you being
that way and so I really do think with
any of these communities having that
mind set up you're gonna fail you may
not find the right one let go of some
cost bias but also let me show up and
actually give some value here yeah and
not just take as soon as I get here and
I think that's really an important
mindset for trying to find your place
where you don't feel isolated is you
showing up and being helpful -
absolutely when in doubt find ways to
contribute and and I think you'll start
to find a community because by the way
you also start to feel the fulfillment
that you get from giving that you cannot
get from just consuming or taking
you